I see I see many people banging their
heads against a brick wall though a few
of you have banged your heads against
the brick wall so successfully I made a
hole in the wall like oh I can see the
side now that's one number we have so
like I promise I will show you two ways
of doing this the first way is the hard
way but you do actually learn something
kind of useful from doing the hard way
which you wouldn't do by learning the
easy way but hopefully during the
process of doing the hard way you will
work out the easy way of some of you
already have okay so the hard way is
basically the way that we've already
been doing it for past questions okay so
let's have a look at this so far we've
been taking a inverse trig graph and
then comparing it to sort of a suitable
tree graph which we know how to do it
and it's for big integrals out of this
okay so what kind of area am I going to
be after what a trim here to here okay
in the answer is you turn everything
sideways right so this minus four on
five two four and five which were X
batteries before they becomes Y
batteries yeah right so there's one
there's minus one so it's gonna look
someone is you vote for Fitz there and
minus 4/5 there okay you draw your lines
across and you should get much the same
kind of area okay
now what I'm gonna have to do is work
out right there's some rectangles here
that I can draw and I'm gonna either add
or subtract some areas that I get from
this entering Miss and that will give me
the area I'm after
okay well remembering that less you
remember that integrating a tree graph
will give you an area bounded with the
x-axis right what are the best areas to
pick because they're multiple different
ones okay so I'm going to suggest
probably if we take on this value here
okay now if this is 4/5 4/5 right what
on this x value being
and you could give me you can get
decimal for that obviously but where
does the decimal come from think about
what this corresponds to on this graph
four-fifths is here you know this goes
across to here what is this what one of
the Y values correspond to they
correspond to cos inverse of whatever
your x value is right so this should be
cos inverse of 4/5 okay just like say
close inverse of 0 is pi/2 and cos
inverse of minus 1 is pi okay so if I
can work out how high this is or how far
across this is this value here is cos
inverse for on five okay now that that
blocks off a little rectangle there and
I can work that out to work out the
other part of it I can integrate and get
this area under that part okay okay so
that's good that's still with that part
okay now what happens over here
well if I integrate around here you know
the most suitable kind of area that you
work out bound into the x-axis will be
this area right because that's between
cos x and the graph sorry cos x any axis
right yeah no this is the hard way MoBay
oh okay sorry I get again I get a
rectangle okay and then I've got this
little green area and I have to
integrate to work that out right now
this is cos inverse of 4 & 5 that was
the x value once the x value for this
little part here we use the same logic
what's the exact value I like it cause
invested four and five yeah so I said
look I'm four or five up here so going
down this is close enough so I'm gonna
get the same kind of thank you
cos inverse of minus four or five this
time because that's where I am okay so
um what rectangle is oh my god let's
let's do this first
we're trying to work out this area the
first rectangle I have up here okay
length sorry well length times height so
the width there is close in verse four
and five right whatever that happens to
be and the height is 4/5 so there's that
rectangle okay now I could do with this
green part but I'm gonna leave that off
for a second you'll see why okay let's
have a look at the other rectangle how
high is the other rectangle the bottom
one also four or five because it's the
same distance four and five now how wide
is it's not same with zero to coz
inverse of minus four or five okay so
that's what I've got this is two
rectangles being added okay now here's
the tricky thing you know try to
remember what definite integrals mean
okay but I integrate from here to here
okay I want to add this one and it's
above the axis I want to subtract this
one and it's below the axis right so
actually what I want to add is this one
integral that the two green areas are
what integral right
what other upper and lower bounds I
started cause in verse four and five
okay and I end at Cosi versus
okay so they're there to their the fact
that parts underneath the actors have
parts above is actually exactly what I
want because I want to add this area and
take this one away okay you see that
okay not slowly if that's making sense
okay that's enough right now what am I
actually integrating it's just cause
this wrote X okay now what is this equal
to
yeah I can't do very much with this so
I'm just going to leave it at the front
but I will factorize it because okay now
what is this equal to
okay I'm going to turn this cause when I
integrate its primitive ears what's the
premium project it's just sign right and
I'm going to evaluate it at these
boundaries right so cos inverse of four
five and quasi verse of minus four five
okay so I'm gonna do it this boundary
and subtract it from this boundary okay
so I've got this these two rectangles
out the front okay now I'm gonna write
this out longhand even though you
probably could skip this step okay but
this is why it's at the hard way right
sign of my upper boundary sign of cos
inverse minus four and five in bracket
minus my lower boundary
okay now I run out of space over here
but you have a look at those last two
terms right we've been doing these
questions to death over the last week
and a half right side of clothes in
vests or something and son cause you've
missed something else okay
what's that equal to I mean just think
of the first one sign of coziness of
minus four and five now you can draw the
triangle you do the quadrants that kind
of thing you may remember that sign of
consumers and by extension cause of sine
inverse is the square root of one minus
x squared it's always positive whenever
you put sine and cos inverse or causing
some units the other times Google+ so
what kind of triangle is this ratio at
you
what kind of right angle triangle is it
it's a 3 4 5 triangle right so if the
COS ratio is 4 & 5 this sine ratio will
be 305 right okay now I'm running out of
space so I'm just gonna clear backwards
here we go so I've got the two
rectangles out the front now this first
side of cos inverse you've told me is
three on five what about the next one
it's in exactly the same kind of
triangle right another 3 4 5 triangle so
minus 3 over 5 now hold on who does that
mean what does that you know what does
that tell us about this diagram we ought
to be actually kind of predicting that
right because remember I told you when
we started doing these questions
yesterday it will pay off if you
actually draw your graphs with some
reasonable accuracy don't just do
whatever kind of squiggle looks like a
sine curve okay
what cost curve in this case because
I've drawn it with reasonable sort of
accuracy you can see in the green areas
are equal okay ones above and ones below
so you should expect them to cancel out
exactly okay so you get this this is
just the two rectangles
now at this point you may get out your
calculator and I'll run that through and
then you'll get some meaningless decimal
and you press the fraction button
nothing happens so you're like okay I
guess it's done right and you sort of
should be that surprised that the the
calculator comes to be something
meaningful because four and five and
minus four and five they're not exactly
our age it's not like a root 3 and 2 or
1/2 or something like that ok but this
is actually equal to something okay the
reason why you can know is that you've
got this kind of causing person
something and cleanser versus of - the
same thing okay
now I'm continuing that that's equal to
something concrete how could you work
out what it is now this is the useful
thing which we're gonna work out but a
hard way is going to tell us if you have
some space up on the side I want you to
consider this okay that's that's what
I've got here really but I've got it
with actual values okay now what's it
equal to right well these are these are
both ankles right you can think of
they're both as angles okay cause he
misses something cause he misses the
wheels so I'm gonna call this let's just
call it alpha I don't know what it is
but it's I think it's equal to something
what is it equal to
okay how'd you go about working out what
is even what could you do to this yeah
okay so I like to also news okay the
first one is I know what Kazi versus
that makes it looks like there isn't I
know it cause inverse of minus X look
like it's gonna flip horizontally right
and if you can do addition of ordinates
that works fine okay but wanna press you
over the last few days I mean using
inverse trig functions and we've been
putting together with treats agents
right I think this is a perfect
candidate for doing this okay so what
I'm gonna do this is the second thing
that you do this is I'm going to take
cause of both science ok so what's gonna
happen obviously I'll get plugs alpha on
the right hand side
what's the expansion for cos a plus B
which expansionism
it's it's close cause by this side side
okay so I'm going to get cause of this
in cause of that - sigh okay I don't
forget at the very start I probably
should have noted that I actually have a
restriction on X right so therefore I
could know some things about this what's
causing positiveness
of X in this domain what's it equal to
it's just equal to X right what about
this in this domain it's the same as
this book with a place right - okay now
let's see how good your memory is sign
of cause averse what we get you get the
square root right in fact you get B on
the top half of the unit circle okay
what do you expect will happen when I
put a minus X in there it's gonna be
this again but it'll be sweats so minus
x times what it's X I'm just going to
get at one minus x squared that's equal
to cos alpha I can do some cific here
write minus x squared
what's this -
X Squared's cancel put alpha on the left
hand side because that's where it kind
of belongs
so what's alpha what's alpha cos of what
angle gives you minus 1 it's it's right
here isn't it cause off PI gives you
minus 5 okay so from old bat I take that
now down here right this is cos inverse
of X plus cos inverse of minus X
whatever your values for X are you're
gonna get high this is why your
calculator will not give you an exact
tank answer cuz it can't it can't you
can't do PI's okay yeah yeah if you
divide your answer by PI it'll give you
4/5 but just by pressing I mean most
people don't try that because they don't
think it might be a multiple of Pi or it
might be you know each other